[Music]
whoa and welcome to chess openings is
played as always my name is Caleb Denby
and I will be your host here today and
the topic for today I wanted to focus on
the open Catalan rather as opposed to
the closed Catalan the Catalan I feel
like is one of those openings that a lot
of players struggle with from the black
from the black side white seems to get a
small nagging advantage without really
risking anything it's one of those
openings where it's difficult to find a
way to really pose serious problems to
white but I do believe that the open
Catalan is the best choice for black the
closed Catalan of course has its
supporters as well but I do think the
open is easier to play and so tonight I
want to take you through sort of the
three main variations that you're gonna
face against the catalan and make some
recommendations in each one why I think
some lines are better than some others
and hopefully by the end of it you'll
have a pretty well-rounded view of what
the Catalan is how to play against it
and you'll feel more than comfortable
the next time you face it so to start
off with I have a game between Levon
Aronian and women's number one player
how you fun former women's world
champion of course and this is a game
where how you found introduced a
relatively new idea I'm not sure if it
was you know 100 percent a novelty the
move that she played but this is the
game that sort of brought this move back
into the limelight the game that has
become very relevant as the move that
was played in this game is now played
quite often against the Catalan so to
start with in this game they arrived at
the Catalan via this move order d4 c4
Knight f3 and d5 and now g3 so of course
with Knight c3 I'm going to transpose
into some Queens gambit declined
positions with g3 white is
going ahead and committing to playing
the Catalan now do you take c4 is
playable immediately but I like delaying
it so we have Bishop e7 Bishop g2
castles and castles and this is sort of
the starting position for us here now in
this position if you play a move like c6
you are playing the closed cattle and
you are keeping the center closed
specifically keeping this diagonal
closed and this is a perfectly fine way
of playing the downside is that I do
think it makes White's play a little bit
more free why it's going to be you know
developing this piece out this way
developing the Queen out to c2 and at
the end of the day you're gonna have to
be facing some efore threats and some
threats on the Queen side as well so the
line I'm recommending is the open
Catalan which of course happens after D
takes c4 with D takes c4
you now open this diagonal and open up
the center and the play becomes a lot
more direct so this is more or less our
starting tabia for tonight's lecture
those first ones that white played are
pretty consistent to arrive at the
Catalan Fink heading the Bishop Knight
f3 d 4 and C 4 and and castling and so
here is where we really make our
decision d take c4 now from here there
are three main options that I'm gonna
cover here today I will briefly mention
just at the start of the hour here that
white does have some other various
options and I'll I'll point those out in
this game we're gonna look at the main
move which is Queen c2 there's also the
choice of playing the move Knight e5 for
white that we're gonna look at next
there's also the choice of plane Queen
a4 for white but we'll come to find out
that Queen i-4 is quite often just seen
as a slightly worse version of Queen c2
and that's why Queen c2 is more popular
and then just a brief mention to the
other options white has when I can also
play Knight a3 trying to regain the pawn
in 8c 3 or an IBD 2 all in this main
position I think even a4 has been played
but these are really sidelines that
came out here for example of 93 the move
knight c6 is actually quite playable for
black highlighting the fact that this
pawn is just a little bit awkward here
if Knight a3 we can actually capture
this knight on the board and we get a
strange version of the lines that we're
gonna see 95 and with something like
Knight bTW - I think even the move b5 is
is quite strong so those are our very
much sidelines we're not gonna focus on
those
we're gonna focus in this game in
particular on the main main line with
Queen c2 no players with the black
pieces have tried all sorts of things
here the move a 6 is kind of the
front-runner here as far as main
variations and now this is the reason
why Queen c2 is seen as slightly better
than Queen I for they both have the idea
of playing queen takes c4 but with the
Queen on c2 after a 6 White has a very
serious option of playing the move a4
and this is designed to sort of prevent
this move b5 for a little bit so while
you can play like this and there's a lot
of theory to go around there in this
game how you find introduced the idea of
playing b6 in this position now b5 has
also been played in the past and it is a
very serious move it's responded to by a
for most most of the time then b4 and
you get a very interesting position but
the move b6 was how he founds idea not
going to steps now right off the bat
white does have a few options here at
first glance it looks as though you've
done nothing to prevent Queen takes c4
and while this is true thanks to our
move order here we get to develop our
Bishop to a very comfortable diagonal on
b7 and queen takes c4 is is really not a
very testing variation to look out for
the game might continue with Knight c3
and IB d7 rook over to d1 and c5 and
black once once black has achieved c5
this is sort of the freeing move that
black was looking for and after c5 in
this variation it does become very easy
to play
if D takes c5 highlighting this pin we
can just simply recapture with the
bishop and then play would continue from
here for
we'll be four but should be seven this
should be two well sorry we actually we
can even insert some funny business here
by taking on f2 but let's say but should
be seven it should be two and now I move
like rook c8 is okay for black so Queen
takes c4 isn't the main variation by any
stretch of the imagination it's sort of
playing into blacks and black played b6
and if blank is allowed to play Bishop
e7 Bishop e7 sort of unhindered then
black is really not going to have any
problems there's one obvious tactical
downside to playing this move b6 and
that's what was tried in this game by
Levon Aronian and this is sort of if
you're gonna refute this line by black
this is the way you're gonna do it so
does anybody in the YouTube chat see
that that move here for for white the
move to sort of try and refute blacks
opening play it's pronounced as who you
phone
how are you fun thank you for the
pronunciation help this is always a
struggle for me does anybody see the
most testing variation I'm not getting
it out yet we have two answers both
correct it's the move 95 this is sort of
the the main testing variation and that
is probably the reason that this line
was not so popular for quite a while and
so with 95 obviously there is a problem
for black the problem is this rook on a8
and at first glance it looks as though
that white is sort of just winning here
the only really playable most looked
like 95 or c6 this is the only way to
really save the rook and these are not
very happy most for example if you play
95 there's all sorts of options here for
for white you can even just capture this
and this Knight is not at all
comfortable on this d5 square and
obviously if you play the move c6
you're just sort of asking for trouble
this pawn is immediately hanging if
white ones to capture it and in fact
probably he should and this is just not
ideal for for black quiet obviously
going down upon but there is a third
move in the position and that's the move
that
who you Fon plays in this position and
that's Queen takes d4 and this is just
simply in exchange sacrifice but
thankfully it is a good exchange
sacrifice for black and black is going
to find sort of level play after this
sacrifice as we see in this game it's
not as though black is winning with this
exchange sacrifice but it is a perfectly
playable position and it's a very
interesting position which is why I I
like it for playing against the Catalan
because Catalan players sort of have a
reputation for getting this this sort of
boring long-term advantage and with this
I do think that black effectively
neutralizes it and creates sort of an
interesting imbalance with the exchange
sacrifice so once this has been played
white is sort of obligated to capture
this rook and then Queen takes d5
regains the minor piece now there are a
few things that can be played here but
it really is in White's best interest to
evacuate this Bishop sort of as quickly
as possible if white gets a little bit
carried away with a tempting looking
moon for like Bishop f4 we're gonna get
met with community I've and then all of
a sudden Bishop f3 Knight g4 and white
is sort of being forced to create more
weaknesses on the Kings side with moves
like this then immediately e5 is quite
strong and if you're not careful you
might just sort of get run over by a
move like Bishop takes h4 so very very
quickly things can go wrong for white if
white isn't really aware of the the
proper way to play against this and just
to show you the line this would be sort
of disastrous for white there should be
seven for example f3 is forced 23 check
for and things sort of a fall apart
quite quite quickly for white in this
specific line of course this is not what
Levon Aronian did but it goes to show
you how quickly things can actually go
wrong for white if he or she is not
prepared so in this game Levon Aronian
plays the best move which is Bishop f3
and Bishop f3 is better than Bishop g2
for a couple of reasons one of those
reasons is the lines that we just took a
look at things like Queen arrived in 94
are a lot more difficult to
obtained with this Bishop on f3 the
bishop on f3 also does a nice job of
supporting this pawn back on e 2 if
anything bad were to happen to it now
that this Bishop is placed here Bishop
f4 does become a pretty serious threat
kickin our Queen and that's why the next
move is ninety five just keeping an eye
on this square now the time has finally
come for white to regain the pawn so a
queen takes e4 is pretty natural and
after this we are going to develop not
to be 7 anymore
but to a6 with tempo on the Queen and
black now has some nice pressure on on e
2 and the volunter own Ian I believe
picks the best square for his Queen in
this game various moves can be played
queenie for even but I do think a 4 is
the best square for this Queen it put
some pressure on this Bishop making it
awkward for this night to develop and
even pressures a 7 sort of indirectly
and from here it does seem as though the
black concretely only has one pawn for
the exchange and you know historically
that's been seen as an advantage for the
side with the exchange of course we have
3 plus 1 equal ink 4 and the rook worth
5 4 is less than 5 so you'd rather have
the exchange in most of these cases
however black does actually have some
very concrete positional gains in this
position in particular we'll see in this
game who you fund starts with the move
c5 and this is a great way to play for
black the point of c5 is basically just
to say I am going to sort of take over
the center in the Queen side with this
extra pawn and if you're not careful
moves like Knight c6
moves like 94 and you can very very
easily be run over all together with
this lack of development that you have
on the Queen side for example just
imagine a night landing on d4 on on this
turn obviously it really can't happen
but a knight from this square and would
very much pressure f3 pressure e2 and
white is going to find himself in and
quite a quite a great deal of trouble in
the game rook e1 was actually Levon
Aronian choice and this is not my
favorite move
of all time it does just provide more
support for the e to pawn you can even
think about expanding this pawn out to
the e4 square on some occasions just to
get rid of this annoying Knight but for
the moment it's sort of just a solid
defensive move that LaVon was trying
there are other moves here for white
really from this position it is just
going to be a chess game so if you're
not comfortable playing down the
exchange like this then this isn't going
to be one of those cases where opening
theories sort of guides you into a
totally comfortable position after the
exchange sacrifice you do fully
sacrifice this exchange in and you're
not really planning on getting it back
anytime soon
so that's sort of something you have to
be ready for if you want to play this
opening line but I do think it is quite
worth it here in light of the move that
how you fund played against Turkey one
which is going to be the move b5 taking
more space players with the white pieces
have sort of tread this move Knight a3
on occasion just highlighting that he
wants to control these squares in
particular and against this various
moves have been played by black as well
we can see seven is one of them and
after a move like d1 black sort of just
takes over the center with the bishops
and this is definitely one way of
playing but let's focus on our main game
which goes rook e1 and then b5 by black
and now who you Fon is just sort of
taking over on the Queen side feeling
the pressure a little bit LaVon actually
offers up a queen trade not wanting to
let this active centralized Queen sort
of stand and from here knight c6 was who
he funds try and this move may not be
actually the most accurate now after
Knight c3 white sort of as natural
development and honestly keeping the
Queen's is is a pretty great way of
playing for black and if you are going
to trade the Queen's well do it with
tempo and that way you have time to play
this move b4 and you really do sort of
hamper White's development in in this
manner so one of those situations where
developing always you know not the worst
idea
but perhaps black could have gone for a
little bit more
if you move like before after taking an
e4 and now these pieces remain awkward
sorry if you don't really want to play
move like 92 blocking in your bishop and
you really can't find a good square for
your bishop play Bishop d2 well that's
where your knight was supposed to go
sort of so it could have been
interesting instead the knight c6 and
now white does get to develop with
Knight to c3 how you fun continues
naturally with rook to d8 and is sort of
not in much danger now we see rook d1 by
Levon sort of admitting that Ricky one
was perhaps not the most accurate
repositioning this rook now to be on a
slightly better open file I hope you
found now does sort of flinch first and
captures on e4 we see Bishop takes e4 by
white and now this Knight does land on
d4 and I think simply this is just going
to be enough compensation for black with
these powerful central Knights to more
than justify sort of giving up this
exchange here in the game Levon played
Bishop takes on d5 and rather than take
on d5 immediately how you fun actually
inserts a pretty clever move b4 and the
point is now we'd rather take the night
instead of the bishop in this specific
case because this Knight is defending
the e2 square and so if this night falls
then we get to munch munch munch on all
the juicy pawns and that's exactly what
happens in the game this should be three
is sort of the only move if you come
back in this direction then this is sort
of just devastating don't want this at
all
so Bishop b3 and after B takes c3 if B
takes c3 and I take C to check King g2
this is why we sort of needed the G to
square for King and now I move like
Knight c3 would be fine how you fund or
who you fund and certs Bishop e7 check
first
now after f3 so you traded the rooks and
hope you fun captures on c3 and we
arrived at this end game which is
arguably slightly better for whites but
with these two strong bishops for black
really black should have no problem
holding this and to be found had no
problem holding this in the game Nimue
Bishop d2 was lavon's choice and now
after Knight takes D 1 or at XD 1 black
left with a bishop pair and Bishop d5
played in the game Rick b1 g5 dealing
with any back rank made threats King f2
Bishop takes a two rook a one Bishop t5
Bishop c3 f6
Burke takes a seven king f7 King III any
5h4
rather h4 captures captures h5 for takes
takes King e6 check Bishop d6 check and
then to avoid any sort of danger
LaVon actually captures on d6 and they
agreed to a a draw here obviously I sort
of sped through that end game but that's
mainly because the endgame is not really
the point here the point was you can get
sort of an active game with black using
this variation and that is the line I'm
going to recommend to you for the black
pieces against the main main variation
of a Catalan let's go back and review it
really quick because I do think there is
one sort of moment that I skipped over
that we're going to take a look at next
so we have all the cattle and moves
castles castles so we take on c4 Queen
c2 is the main variation and b6 is the
idea by who you fund that she uses here
now the main variation that we took a
look at is 95 we also briefly mentioned
the move Queen takes d4 but we're going
to see that the move Bishop g5 is
perhaps the trickiest approach by white
and so we'll take a look at that next
but ninety five in this game black it
has to take on d4 wait more or less has
to take on a8 if Queen takes e5 f 3 is
the best Square for the bishop not
allowing Queen h5 and 94-95 now by black
keeps an eye on the F 4 square we have
Queen takes d4 Bishop a6 Queen a4 and
now c5 by black and this is sort of just
the the start of the middle game
position from here there are many
options for both sides but largely the
idea is for black get your rook to the
center expand on the Queen side try to
get this night to d4 and then life is is
reasonably comfortable for black okay
any questions on our main variation
before we move on
to the next example white is black
never develop his bishop with tempo okay
Manny answering his own questions
what if Bishop takes c6 not sure where
you're mentioning that Manny
unfortunately yep not sure well in that
case I think we are ready to move on
here so let's take a look at another
game this one between Studer and Etienne
back row I think these were both
grandmasters playing in this game in
this case Tudor starts with the move d4
we have Knight f6 c4 e6 Knight f3 d5 g3
there should be seven Bishop g2 castles
castles arriving at our main position
here D takes c4 Queen c2 b6 and then
this is the game that white triad Bishop
g5 this I've called it the trickiest of
White's options and it's definitely one
that needs to be on your radar and it's
actually surpassed 95 as the most
popular move in this position for white
sort of at a a top level and the reason
for that is that this exchange sacrifice
has sort of just been seen to be fine
for blacks so players what the white
pieces have turned to Bishop g5 instead
to try to prove an advantage but we'll
see as a team back row did with the
black pieces here it really is sort of a
paper tiger as they say you know kind of
an empty threat with Bishop g5 so there
is just one thing you need to avoid
after Bishop g5 and thing you need to
avoid is playing this move Bishop e7
this is just losing now for pluck right
out of the gate so who sees the tactic
that's white cleverly set up with the
move Bishop g5 who sees wait to move and
win in this position
wait to move and win here what do you
guys got for me
yes Poosh does have it it is Bishop
takes f6 black is obliged to recapture
and then this move Knight g5 is rather
annoying checkmate is threatened as is
b7 capturing the full piece does not
preserve the material because Bishop
takes b7 and this work on a 8 is
indefensible now we don't even have our
clever Queen takes d4 in exchange for it
97 takes takes and this is not a could
exchange sacrifice for black any longer
so this is something you absolutely must
avoid that's why the main move here is
just the move Knight to d5 offering up
this trade of bishops and blocking off
this diagonal for the moment Bishop
takes you seven Queen takes e7 and now
white most often it goes ahead and
recaptures here on the c-4 Square and
now we sort of fall back to what kind of
happens after Queen takes c4 immediately
this is going to be pretty similar to it
with black just sort of developing
naturally and eventually going for a c5
move in an effort to just totally
equalize in this game The Crow goes for
Bishop a6 Queen c2 and now 97 just
supporting the c5 break we have Knight
c3 pressuring d5 and simply c5 by black
and black is doing totally totally fine
here so once again this is sort of the
fallback plan if white does something
rather slow with this pieces doesn't
create a ton of threats or especially
when he doesn't go for this line where
he wins the exchange in exchange for the
d4 pawn and the e5 Knight black just
develops calmly gets his pieces out
sometimes with tempo if possible on the
Queen on c4 and then plays the move c5
and after c5 there if there aren't
immediate complications then black is
doing totally totally fine and you can
just bring your hooks to the open file
and there's absolutely no reason why
black should be worse in this game white
tried to go for Knight takes d5 we have
e takes d5 and then rook F T
one supporting the center simply Bishop
back to be seven now it sort of served
its purpose on a six forcing this Queen
off of the act of c-4 square and so
Bishop back to be seven now is calmly
defending the center pawns against
White's threats so sorry not work F do
you want her to fe1 rather Rick F do you
want of course would hang this pawn and
be totally fine for black rook e1 and
now Bishop e7 forcing both of these
awkward moves by White Queen a4 must
played in the game Rick f e8 and just
takes control of this half open file and
now we Rick a to c1 was played and
simply a six by black and a six sort of
indirectly creates the threat of playing
b5 and C for following up with things
like b4 and just expanding on the Queen
side rather than allow that white did
take this moment to capture on c5 and
now rather than take back with the
knight accepting an isolated Queens pawn
black captures back with the pawn and we
have now a hanging pawn structure by
black and this proved to actually be
pretty good for black as a tea and does
go on to win this game using this
structure once again though just a
comfortable middle game position neither
side really having any kind of advantage
here but there's a lot of play in the
position that's that's the point as
black is getting imbalances getting
something to play for and that's why I
do like these these variations in the
game Queen a5 was played or kc8 is
natural to defend this pawn Knight back
to d2 tries to put some pressure simply
Knight f8 by black prepares to reroute
this night and we have E 4 by white
breaking down the light squares and d4
opens this diagonal and maintains the
structure Knight b3 now is pressuring
this pawn we have 96 to defend the
structure York c4 Rick d8d 1 and now f5
was a pretty nice idea by back row to
open the long diagonal and actually
start fighting for a win white doesn't
dare capture this pawn on account
of the move Knight g5 when you are sort
of getting checkmated on the the Kings
side here if you don't do anything well
look out
it should takes g2 King takes g2 and
Queenie for check is disastrous so white
doesn't open this diagonal just yet
instead chooses the move rook e1 to
support the center F takes e4 it should
takes Bishop takes rook takes Queen f7
now on the new half open file
challenging the f2 pawn Queen d2
queena 5 Queen d3 okay fate its hits f2
so f4 and now the winning move by black
here is of course the move g5 just
blasting open the Kings side and with
these strong pawns in the center white
finds half of his army sort of stranded
on the Queen side Queen f3 that's not
what G takes out for and now after h4
this is sort of just desperation for
white and it's completely winning for
black kind of out of nowhere and that f1
Erika fates are key 1 Queen f6 or okay
for nice 7 and switching the arrow keys
now Rick a5 Queen b6 and after f3 this
is just hopeless just hopeless with this
pawn on f2 and these two pawns marching
their way down the board a very nice win
by at Tampa crow so with that I think
I'm putting to rest these lines after b6
hopefully you have a good idea of what
you're doing in all of these variations
now it is just a nice fun way of getting
a game against the Catalan then I'm
recommending now with the remainder of
the lecture I want to focus on the next
two most popular moves which rather than
Queen c2 are going to be the move 95 in
this position as well as the move Queen
a4 in this position so let's take a look
at those starting off with the more
testing move Knight e5 in my opinion so
switching over to a game now between
renoir and Brandon Jacobson Brandon
Jacobson is actually a player who's been
to st. Louis before played in numerous
tournaments here and is still moving on
up in the chess world but let's see what
happened here
in the game d4 we of course arrive at
the Catalan castles castles black
captures on c4 and now rather than Queen
c2 we do see the move 95 and the point
of this move is pretty direct you
immediately open up the LightSquared
Bishop challenging this diagonal you
also threatened attack to take this pawn
with the night rather than queen and you
sort of force blacks hand to go into one
of two or three variations here I'm
gonna recommend the main move which is
to play knight c6 black players have
also been trying to move c5 here but I
do think that white does end up with
sort of a slight edge in these c5
variations so let's focus on knight c6
now against knight c6 there's sort of
two options for white I am only going to
really focus on the move Knight takes c6
because I do think this is the most
testing line Bishop takes c6 once again
hasn't really been the the most testing
in my opinion let's briefly look at it
Bishop takes c6 B takes Knight takes is
a fork so Queenie eight Knight takes you
seven Queen takes e7 and now the game
can progress in a variety of ways most
often the move Queen a four is chosen
and the reason is chosen is to try and
combat the idea of c5 by offering white
the option of playing Queen to a3 with a
pin but against Queen a4 black and sort
of just break with E 5 and now life is
is pretty comfortable I think for for
black here
the only reason white can try to claim
an advantage is one obviously white has
an extra pawn although we'll see it may
not stay that way and to these pawns may
look a little bit less comfortable than
these pawns so let's just follow the
variation a little bit Queen d3 Rick 88
mean III Queen h5 f 3 now Bishop c4 and
now after Knight c3 brick Fe eights
Queen f2 Knight and d5 you kind of see
that black has activated all of the
pieces ton of pressure on eight
- and I think almost every game that
does reach this position has actually
ended in a drop just for example a
rookie one that takes c3 you take c3 and
now I'll move like Queen i5 and every
one of white spawns is weak white does
have an extra pawn though so you
shouldn't really be worse just for
example efore 53 is simply regaining
this pawn without too much controversy
here white doesn't even attempt to
defend it in most cases so that's a
quick overview of Bishop takes c6 white
sort of liquidates a ton of pieces black
breaks in the center and then life kind
of goes on rather though Knight takes c6
I do think is the move that could
potentially cause black some problems so
let's see what happened in this game we
have Knight takes c6 b takes c6 and now
Knight a3 is the main idea once again if
Bishop takes c6 this one isn't really
too threatening black simply moves the
rock out of the way tonight c3 there
should be 7 and black is doing quite all
right here so night a 3 is the most
testing going for this pawn and now
black captures on a3 and after B takes a
three we get a very very strange pawn
structure where everybody's pawns are
doubled or tripled and isolated and it
is definitely a pretty forcing game here
there are two main branches for Black
Knight d5 and Bishop a6 are both
playable I like the move Bishop a6 so
it's what I'm gonna recommend Queen d2
here
rook over to b8 is natural getting the
rook on the open file also getting it
off of this long diagonal now after
Queen a5 there are two moves in this
position one move is rook b6 and one
move it's queen CA and now I actually
spent quite a lot of time looking at the
move rook p6 and I did not like the the
positions and the variations that that I
was coming up with looking at previous
games looking at the computer
recommended and so I very much am going
to recommend the move Queen c8 rather
than Rick p6 I do think black might
actually be ending up in a little bit of
trouble here if you play the move rook
b6 so Queen C is my recommendation and
now anybody's anybody is playing the
move a4 here with white with
the idea of activating this bishop along
this diagonal also taking away in the b5
Square from any of the black pieces and
now Rick d8 is very very sensible just
getting on the half-open file
challenging this pawn bishop a3 now by
white is by far the most common and now
a rook takes d4 is very very natural
gaining another pawn for the Troubles
now rook have to be one is most often
played and now the move rook takes the
one is potentially playable for black
but I do prefer this line with rook b6
which is a bit more common of course the
obvious downside direct b6 is Bishop c5
and now after rook d7 we have actually
so far followed quite a number of games
notably we're following a game between
Wesley so in Hikaru Nakamura from the
2016 Sinquefield Cup we're also
following a game between David Hale and
Micky Adams there's also a couple of the
games but those are the two big names
that we have so far following of course
we're also following our main games so
far and then this is where it starts to
branch out and all of the games white in
this position play the move rook to d1
the idea being were just challenging
this file before capturing this rook and
here a move like rook b8 isn't really
going to be super comfortable for black
you do save the exchange but you face
the move or a takes d7 and they take c7
and Bishop takes a 7 and now after okay
eights Bishop d4 White has the two
bishops the material count is black is
technically up upon but it's a triple
pawn and it's against doubled pawns so
it's a little bit unclear if the
material matters and actually why does
immediately regaining this pawn here so
I don't really like this way of playing
this is actually how Micky Adams chose
to play against Daniel David Howell I
thought his name was Daniel for his
second losing my mind over here but
Nicky Adams did end up drawing that game
but I'm still not a huge fan of that
line there's also the movie rook takes D
1 and that is playable here this has
actually been played the most often but
after York takes d1 white does have the
open file and we sort of transposed a
lot of lines after rook b8 there's also
the move h6 which is actually Hikaru
Nakamura's choice against
Wesley's so but unfortunately for a
corona Cabrera he ended up losing that
game so I was not a huge fan of this
line either with age six sort of just
making a waiting move and so that's how
I ended up finding this game between
Brandon Jacobson and tango a ring guar I
no idea how to pronounce his name I
apologize again but he came up with this
move 95 and I quite like this move
because it allows white and opportunity
to kind of go wrong here white will
never capture c6 well sometimes white
might capture c6 the kind of the point
is that so far it hasn't been worth the
tempo to take on c6 after 95 there are
of course various options for white that
are all you know totally totally
reasonable so this is kind of where the
opening theory I think can kind of end
we are following multiple games until
this point where 95 makes this game
unique now many of you are probably
wondering why not capture this rook and
taking this rook is totally fine for
white but after C takes b6 you sort of
solve blacks issue of having these
triple pawns and it's just another
comfortable exchange sacrifice this
Queen could come on back to a square
like d2 or even II won if you prefer and
then a move like c5 could be coming
controlling a ton of squares a simple
move like h6 could happen as well and
it's just going to be a game from this
position you know just for example moves
can be played just more chess moves to
to happen here
so that's Bishop takes p6 I don't want
to talk too much about it because you
know while this might be seen as the
sort of the main variation those
positions really are going to be
comfortable for black you just sort of
eventually get your pawns rolling on the
Queen side just try to activate your
pieces get your queen out get the rook
on to a regional square and from there
play is just going to follow pretty
naturally you know it's it's not a
terribly difficult position for black to
play you know you sort of have this one
huge edge in exchange for the exchange
and you just sort of play around it
in the game though Brandon Jacobson
shows the movie 4 which is a perfectly
fine move and forces this night off of
the nice d5 square and so now the night
comes back to f6 but unfortunately now
for white now really is the time to go
in for these variations you can bring
this Queen over to e5 and then black is
going to bring the stroke in to d3 but
the upside now is that black is at least
sacrificing exchange to get to this
position whereas with the move played in
the game which is Queen c3 this was
perhaps just a little bit too nonchalant
because now black has a very very strong
move here so black to move and sees an
advantage from this position see if you
guys can can find it here black to move
and seize the advantage what do you guys
have for me
why is this opening not popular it is
very popular in my opinion never see it
in games well one of the main proponents
of the Catalan was Vladimir Kramnik who
of course has now retired and with it
brought away a lot of the Catalan with
them you don't see it at the top level
too often because really black is
supposed to be fine in the main
variations it's you know at the top
level these days they do try and still
prove some kind of advantage in most of
their games so the move is in fact as
the chat is suggesting the move rook d3
and the point now is that you are facing
you were giving might a difficult
decision that he has to face option
number one is to just move the Queen and
allow black to save the exchange but
then of course you've allowed black to
save the exchange hence if he can save
the exchange black probably should save
the exchange here option number two is
to capture on d3 and then capture on b6
but now of course we have even further
fixed black's pawn structure and this
pawn on d3 is going to be massively
massively powerful and when faced with
this decision
brandon jacobson actually said no way am
i playing this position this is way too
good for black with this pawn on d3 and
so he chose to play Queen c2 instead but
now after rook d7 it is just going to be
a comfortable advantage for black so
this was really the moment where white
went wrong with the move Queen c3 much
better is to capture the exchange first
and then place similar positions with an
active Queen on e5 and this pawn not yet
on d3 after rook d3 you do end up in
some similar stuff also notably after a
move like Bishop F 1 sometimes black
doesn't even save this rook although
probably it he should here and go for go
for this similar type of positions that
were offered with rift d3 except down to
exchanges rather than then 1 for example
c5 is a playable move Bishop takes d3 C
takes D 3 and you get a crazy crazy
position where black has rolling past
pawns but has actually offered up two
exchanges
to get here this could be a lot of fun
notably though you know there this is
not forced by by black and things like
this are potentially playable as well
what the move like rook takes d1 being
okay but this is still also definitely
on the cards for black but let's see how
the game finished Queen c2 and now
Knight takes e4 we do end up sacrificing
mixed exchange anyways but now with this
pawn on d3 Brandon unfortunately it just
gets overrun f3 falls the Queen comes
back and it's just way too many pawns
now in the center and Brandon resigned
in this exact position now so a great
game by a ringer ringer right I can't
pronounce his name but great game by him
anyways 95 is a really interesting move
and I think it offers black quite a lot
of opportunity for white to go slightly
awry as he did in this game
alright moving along I did want to take
a look at a game in the third most
popular variation for white which is
this variation with Queen to a4 so let's
jump into it here we have a game between
Fabiana Cara Juana and this one Athan
Anand so of course they played the
Catalan otherwise I would not be talking
about it we have D takes e4 and now
we've looked at Queen c2 in this line
with b6 we've looked at 95 and 96 but
Queen a4 is very much still a move that
that gets played quite often here and so
with Queen I for white is kind of just
allowing black the best version possible
of Queen c2 right Queen c2 is more
popular because after a6 the move a4 is
legal and you don't get to play this
move b5
now with Queen a4 no such luck and I do
think the most popular move in this case
is the best with a 6 and after a 6 black
really doesn't have any problems in this
variation if you are a die-hard b6
player I do think it is potentially
playable in this position as well after
Queen takes c4 you would just transpose
the
stuff we already know and against 95
still Queen takes d4 bishop takes a
queen takes e5 and Bishop back to f3 and
95 we would transpose again with Queen
takes c4 there is potentially like a
queen takes a seven option to look out
for but after Knight c6 life should be
pretty comfortable for black here as
well just a pretty interesting way to go
about it so if you really do like these
b6 lines I do think it is playable here
I have not found a refutation with this
Queen on a4 rather than c2 but it's sort
of the case of you know you don't need
to do this because a6 is just so
comfortable for black so a6 Queen takes
c4 is really the only idea and now just
be 5 by black is is very nice the Queen
comes back to c2 and we developed with
Bishop e7 you sort of get everything
that we want we expand on the Queen side
a little bit when you get our Bishop on
this long diagonal to contest White's
Bishop and we're gonna continue now with
stuff like an eventual c5 quite often we
move Bishop d2 was chosen in this game
and now if neither player is feeling
very ambitious there is a line with
Bishop e4 we can see one Bishop d7 Queen
c2 I should be four we can see one or
after this move you black can deviate
with a move like nine pd7 or white can
deviate with a move like Bishop f4 and
this is just totally fine I'm going to
recommend instead the move that fishy
and non played here which is just Bishop
d6 you sort of just take control of this
f4 to be eight diagonal before white has
a chance to put his own Bishop there
notably if Bishop f4 happens in this
position you're sort of running into
Bishop d6 anyways when you are
challenging this Bishop directly there
are other options here 95 isn't bad a
knight c6 isn't bad either
going for stuff like night before - d5
which is why this Bishop was placed on
d2 and what okay Bishop d2 Bishop d6
Knight age 4 played in this game
offering up this trade of bishops which
vichy accepts now Knight B to d7 and
after E 4 there is the thread of 5 so
black moves the bishop back
and it does seem like black kind of lost
some Tempe by playing Bishop d6 and
Bishop e7 but it's sort of a case of it
it doesn't really matter because blacks
position is just so comfortable
the LightSquared bishop czar off the
board c5 is coming very very quickly and
there's no reason to really be afraid at
all for black to move knight c3 was
played in the game and now black does
expand with the move c5 d c5 was played
in the game night c5 and now it really
is clear to see there's not really any
imbalance that's left white has actually
by taking in this extra space with this
e4 pawn given himself more of a weakness
than an advantage with E for being
something that now has to be defended
and I think black is simply better in
this position Bishop e3 was played in
the game queen d3 offers up a queen
trade Rick AC one fishy takes the
Queen's off the board and takes off the
e4 pawn as well and now just up upon
this she does end up going on to just
win this game brings the King around
brings the rook in and f5 check and now
this is some very clever endgame
business if you want to talk about end
games though attend the endgame class on
Wednesday this is an openings class so
we don't care about of issues beautiful
technique takes the Knights off the
board as well and now here we go and of
issue when they came upon and game by
pushing these two pawns together in
tandem this King not able to stop both
of these pawns simultaneously of course
these pawns defend each other by the
rule of some kind of rectangle don't ask
me about it that's a question for the
endgame class so Bobby
simply resigns in this position so that
was a very very brief overview of the
Queen a4 line but I really don't think
it's very testing at all just a 6 and B
5 and then then Bishop d7 we do have
some extra time left and in order to
fill this time I'm going to look at
another game in the b6 variation cuz
this is what you're going to be facing
most often if you play this way with the
black pieces this Queen c2 move it is
quite common so I wanted to take a look
at
another very famous game that sa to this
variation and that is a game between
ding Lauren and Fabiana Cara Juana
so if ho you font was kind of or who you
found was the introducer of this idea
then this is the game that sort of
really brought it into the top ten and
ever since these two games this idea has
been played a little bit more often so
let's look at this game we have d4
Knight f6 c4 e6 9 f3 d5 and g3
it should be seven and Bishop g2 castles
castles do you take c4 we can see to be
6 by Fabi
and now the move Knight e5 was once
again played by dangler n Queen takes d4
but she takes 8 Queen takes d5 Bishop f3
as I've said is the best square for this
Bishop guarding some squares on the
Kings side also guarding the e2 pawn 95
is natural to stop Bishop f4 as we
talked about Queen takes c4 a6
gaining a tempo now rather than go to a
4 Tingler n actually plays the move
Queen b3 and I do think Queen b3 it's
sort of just objectively a worse square
than a 4 so in light of the first couple
games that we looked at some of the
ideas that black has I'd like you guys
at home to go ahead and try to find
fabi's next move in this position here
fabi's next move keeping in mind some of
these ideas we've looked at in previous
games what do you guys got what you got
for me
find the idea for Fabia
[Music]
Bishop takes you to is not gonna quite
do it for us here rookie one is an
unfortunate pin this was White's idea so
not taking on you two in this case
all right nobody has the idea all right
I'm giving up on you guys the idea of
course is not to continue as we saw in
the game between Aronian and Hui fun
with c5 but rather to play the move
knight c6 immediately as you guys are
getting it now Akash and player both
with the idea you want to bring this
knight to d4 and this is sort of why
Queen b3 is a worse move than Queen i-4
in my opinion Queen I afford did a nice
job of preventing this idea by
challenging both of these squares but
now knight c6 and we're getting this d
f-- d4 square all the faster and only
after this night comes here then we do
have the option of backing it up sort of
with the move c5 King Lauren made a
quick adjustment of his queen now only
now challenging both of these squares
but after Bishop b7 black is comfortable
in defending these pieces Knight c3 was
ding Lauren's choice to develop and now
Fabi does bring this Knight into into d4
and we have quite an interesting
position on our hands once again so this
Bishop is being challenged as is the e2
pawn and ding decided that this was
caused enough to actually exchange it
for this knight on d5 and this is often
what we see in games in this line the
pressure is enough and that white does
end up giving blacks some sort of other
advantage quite often the bishop pair to
go along with his one pawn that he has
for the exchange and so Bishop takes d5
now black has one pawn for me exchange
as well as the bishop pair and
centralized active pieces like this
knight on d4 it should be enough for a
total compensation he takes d5 played in
the game now after Bishop f4 the move
Knight takes c2 check would once again
be a bit of a mistake because rook e1 is
still a devastating threat so Queen f6
instead just removes the Queen from the
threat of capture now Bishop takes c7
was actually pencil e playable here but
black is going to use this open file
White has to come on back and this is
still going to be okay for for black
here
actually Bishop c5 immediately might be
quite strong just going for threats on
f2 for example push it back to f4 a
knight back to e6 and all the pieces are
just coordinating beautifully for black
so not Bishop take c7 in this case but
rather rook a to d1 and now the move c5
is quite natural as I said black looking
to expand with this extra pawn and he
does so he does so here as well with c5
supporting the knight in the center and
it is once again a comfortable position
for Fabi now Queen takes a7 is
potentially playable here but the move
Queen c6 is actually going to be quite
strong and it's kind of a case of where
there's just a lot of Mines for white to
dodge like he's in a minefield right you
know to continue the analogy where else
do you find mines I'm not sure there's
all these tempting options like taking
on c7 and taking an a7 but quite often
they just turn out to not be good for
white as is the case here Queen c6 and
black is actually you know III would go
ahead and say winning in this position
after Queen c6 because the the white
queen is gonna find itself just sort of
getting trapped on a 7 and that's why I
do like this variation because you know
with accurate play both sides you're
fine but if there's just one kind of
misstep by a white then black could very
easily be be winning this game for
example if Queen a4 move b5 all these
squares are covered Queen 85 Rickett
eights in the sky is is dead
well actually Queen c7 is a threat so
Bishop d8 instead queen a 3 B 4 Queen I
for a knight take C to check and this is
slightly more complex than just winning
a free Queen but it is still just going
to be winning taking here for example is
good enough
so now queen takes a seven or other
Bishop III now Knight f3 check is an
interesting set sacrifice by Fabi you
take step 3
and now d4 regains the piece F for D
takes c3 B takes c3 Bishop into f3 and
once again Fabia is on the offensive
threatening all kinds of dangerous
checkmates so rook d3 gets played now it
might be a bit of a mistake for black to
go all in here trying to give checkmate
there is just one variation that keeps
the advantage for whites and doesn't
lose the game immediately but it is good
enough Queen d7 stops Queen h3 offers a
queen trait and will be saving the game
for white
so instead Fabi calmly place to move
Bishop c6 retreating this Bishop for
many tactics also daring white once
again to capture on this square in which
case the move queen of five is actually
going to be winning with threats on the
King side for example Brooke FD one
Queenie four and this is just just over
if you bring this rook to d1 still
Queenie four and you can't play f3
because of this Bishop so Queen back to
b3 instead now once again if we try the
move sorry Queen a5 now the idea is c4
for white if Queen to h3 f3 it's good
enough if Queen here f3 is good enough
once again no this Bishop stays defended
so instead we saw the move Queen a 5 c4
it should be 4 by Fabi
rook d2 Queen h5 f3 and after Bishop
f-35 and Engler n has sort of defend his
sort of defended well enough in order to
escape with a draw
we'll say more maneuvering Queen comes
out to c6 Bishop d6 and Fabi
is doing just fine in this endgame
because despite only having one pawn for
the exchange White's King is far too
weak in order to play for an advantage
here as soon as these major pieces sort
of leave the King try and you know when
somehow threats of checkmate come very
very quickly on the second rank on h3
all sorts of nasty business
so after
three the players agreed to a draw here
so hopefully you guys now have a pretty
good idea of how to play against the
Catalan went through five games pretty
quickly here so against the main line
we're suggesting to move be six against
the other lines well I'm just kind of
suggesting the main lines because they
are in fact good enough
the Catalan spreadin Lee is one of the
more theory heavy openings out of the
move one d4 as far as options for white
but hopefully after this lecture you
guys are now well equipped to handle it
that's going to be it from me here on
youtube tonight if you're watching live
be sure to head over to the twitch
channel for the next edition of tactics
time if you're watching the video this
has been all for tonight thank you so
much for watching my name is Caleb den
booth and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you